au coeur du secteur Sainte-Foy à Québec
il y a une petite église l'église Saint
Mathieu ici le dimanche soir la messe
est célébrée en espagnol
la baie pierre gingra est responsable de
la paroi on retrouve beaucoup
d'immigration
africaine hispanophones portugaise en
eux-mêmes des Malgaches il y a six
églises dans la paroisse mais il y a
assez de fidèles pour en remplir une
seule les nouveaux arrivants qui
représentent le tiers des adeptes
permettent toutefois d'en maintenir
quelques-unes en vie
si on regarde à partir des chiffres et à
partir des nombres on va dire que c'est
une église en déclin le nombre de
prêtres de religieuses de fidèles le
nombre d'églises et la santé des
finances tous ces indicateurs sont à la
baisse
en 1984 des centaines de milliers de
Québécois acclant mes célèbres le pape
Jean-Paul II lors de sa visite dans la
province les messes font ça le comble la
moitié des catholiques participent au
moins une fois par mois des activités
religieuses près de 40 ans plus tard ce
taux à diminué de moitié la bégien gras
à lui-même fermé trois églises et il
sait qu'il enfermera d'autres
accélération du décrochage à partir des
années 80 dès 1920 à 1960 la religion
catholique est à son apogée au Québec
l'église est alors responsable de
l'éducation de la santé et des services
sociaux ce qui lui donne le pouvoir de
définir un bon nombre de normes morales
chez les Québécois la paternité de
l'église sur la société québécoise on
veut en affranchir pierre gingard un Mac
d'ailleurs que ce sont particulièrement
les baby-boomers qui ont déserté les
églises
et on voit des jeunes c'est le cas
d'Antoine Malenfant 37 ans il fréquente
l’église deux fois par semaine il y a
rencontré sa conjointe avec qui il a eu
8 enfants j'attends le 9e et le 10e
décrit de même dans ma face là que pour
moi ce que l'Église enseigne en terme de
morale sexuel
j'adore à ça que les églises soient
vides ça lui importe peu il apprécie que
les fidèles qui se déplacent le fasse
par choix et conviction je dirais qu'il
y a moins de gens qui vont par
convenance autour de moi il y a
plusieurs jeunes familles qui
fréquentent l'église puis qu'ils le font
qu'elles le font par choix des jeunes
fidèles comme lui il y en a peu constate
Gilles routier selon lui les scandales
sexuels de prêtres pédophiles et les
pensionnats pour autochtones ont
contribué au déclin de la popularité ça
entre dans la construction de l'idée que
tout ce qu'on réussit l'Église c'est
d'abuser c'est sûr que ça a pas aidé la
pédophilie mais quand même quantifiée on
ne saura jamais dans les années 60
pierre Bolduc dit avoir été agressé
sexuellement à de nombreuses reprises
par le curé de sa paroi lui en tout cas
a perdu sa foi pour cette raison il y a
une maison qui m'a demandé il a pas
longtemps il dit Pierre est-ce que tout
perdu la foi j'ai dit bah que tu en
penses ce n'est pas la première fois de
son histoire que l'Église catholique
passe à travers une période difficile de
penser que c'est terminé c'est une
grande illusion faut s'attendre à une
longue traversée du désert ici
Marie-Pierre Mercier Radio-Canada Québec